when marie curie shared the 1903 nobel
prize for physics with two other
scientists her husband pierre curie and
henry beckerell she had been the first
woman to win the prize or or maybe we
have no error
so what feels a little fishy is this had
been this had been right over here
we're referring to a specific moment in
the past when marie curie shared the
1903 nobel prize so if we're speaking a
specific moment in the past so if this
is
if this is the present this is the now
and we're speaking about a specific
moment in the past if that is the past
right over there you would just use the
simple past tense so instead of saying
she had been you would just say she was
she was the first woman to win the prize
let's read that without this little
clause here when marie curie shared the
1903 nobel prize for physics with two
other scientists she was the first woman
to win the prize yeah that sounds right
so the error right over here is c
you would use had been that's actually
the the past perfect you kind of throw
that had before the the the before the
the verb to make the past perfect when
you're talking about something that
happened before something in the past so
you could say before i
ate lunch
i
had washed the car so you would use that
past perfect to say look i washed my car
before i did something else in the past
before i actually ate my lunch but here
we're not talking about her doing
something before something in the past
we're talking about something that's
happening in an exact moment in the past
when she won the nobel prize she was the
first woman to win the prize so the
error here is in c